oh
combien sommet entre les deux allemagnes
un rapprochement ultra rapide et la
force de brandebourg qui va s'ouvrir
cette semaine la tragédie roumaine
confirmation de centaines de morts en
transylvanie le dictateur ceausescu a
choisi la répression premières mesures
pour lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine en france moins de visas de
tourisme meilleurs contrôles aux
frontières antenne 2 les nouveaux
programmes sont arrivés le cru 90 enough
beaucoup et il s'harmonise avec et
perfore bonsoir la tragédie roumaine
c'est bien une tragédie que vit la
roumanie en ce moment après
l'immobilisme
après la dictature voici le temps de la
répression sanglante
tous les témoignages qui ont pu être
recueillies auprès de voyageurs confirme
ce que l'on craignait les forces de
l'ordre ont tiré sur les manifestants le
week-end dernier à timisoara près de la
frontière hongroise
la police a chargé la foule il ya
certainement des centaines de morts il
est très difficile d'avoir des
informations précises sur ce qui s'est
passé car la roumanie de ceaucescu cette
idole et du monde extérieur comme pour
se protéger de l'accommodation de la
condamnation unanime à l'ouest comme à
l'est
jérôme baugnies vidil à la frontière
roumano bulgare les camions attendent le
bac trafic à sens unique
cette frontière est fermée comme toutes
les autres frontières de roumanie avec
la hongrie la yougoslavie et l'urss
on sait que de l'autre côté de cette
frontière
la transylvanie est le théâtre d'une
répression particulièrement meurtrière
certains parlent même d'un tiananmen
roumain les informations arrivent au
compte gouttes
joueurs
les vitrines des magasins sont cassés
explique ce camionneur arrivant de
timisoara
il y a dans les rues beaucoup de soldats
de camions militaires et de véhicules
anti-émeutes timisoara est aujourd'hui
en état de siège c'est ici que tout a
commencé
devant cette église où les habitants de
la ville voulait empêcher la déportation
de ce pasteur la stocker ch et de son
épouse enceinte
ils se sont dirigés en cortège vers le
centre de la ville criant des slogans
anti gouvernementaux
c'est alors qu'on eu lieu plusieurs
accrochages
les manifestants criaient à bas la
dictature
ah bah c'est aussi ce coup explique ce
témoin visuel hongrois ils envoyaient
des pierres contre les magasins selon
d'autres témoignages
l'armée a tiré sans sommation dans la
foule les premiers rangs s'effondrer
comme un château de cartes
des femmes et des enfants ont été tués
martine laroche-joubert a rencontré à
berlin
william totok un écrivain roumain exilé
qui a pu joindre timisoara par téléphone
la première fois quand j'ai appelé là
bas c'était dans la nuit de dimanche à
lundi
juste après noël j'entendais le bruit
des mitrailleuses
la personne au bout du fil me confirmer
qu'il y avait des morts j'ai téléphoné
deux heures plus tard à une autre
personne
elle aussi m'a parlé demeure à trois
heures du matin j'ai rappelé à notre ami
c'est lui qui m'a donné le chiffre de 2
à 300 morts bélie stable la réprobation
internationale est unanime à l'est comme
à l'ouest
un régime qui se comporte de la sorte
est un régime condamné à terme estime
roland dumas ministre des affaires
étrangères à varsovie le parlement
polonais a observé une minute de silence
en hommage aux victimes
cependant le camp du 14 rue main nicolas
c'est aussi ce coup poursuit en iran sa
visite officielle dans l'un des rares
pays acceptant encore de le recevoir
je vous le disais tout à l'heure la
roumanie est un pays très fermé en ce
moment il est bien difficile de savoir
ce qui s'y passe réellement
alors jacques merlino vous et il ya
trois semaines à bucarest c'était pour
le congrès du parti communiste roues
1 et ceausescu une fois encore s'était
fait acclamer par les congressistes et
alors comment se fait-il que la roumanie
jusqu'à présent jacques n'est pas du
tout bougé comme les autres pays de
l'est
et bien tout simplement parce que c'est
une dictature comme on peut
difficilement l'imaginer un système
pousse à l'extrême il faut savoir que
l'on compte en roumanie un agent de la
securitate la police secrète pour dix
habitants
on estime à 3 millions de lignes
téléphoniques la capacité d'écouté des
services de renseignement aux mains et
on se souvient peut-être qu'en 1978
ceaucescu avait redonné qu'on recueille
des échantillons d'écriture de toute la
population adulte afin de pouvoir
identifier des auteurs éventuels de
lettres anonymes se sont pas des
chiffres flous que je donne là ce sont
des informations qui ont été
communiquées par le général pas de chez
pas l'ancien chef des services secrets
roumains passer à l'ouest il ya quelques
années
alors bien évidemment cela se traduit
dans la population roumaine par un
sentiment de peur constants un sentiment
extrêmement pesant que l'on saisit au
premier regard
une peur que l'on rencontre rarement à
travers le monde mais alors dans
d'autres pays par exemple en allemagne
de l'est il y avait une police politique
très présente aussi en roumanie c'était
beaucoup
bien pire oui c'est elle sans commune
mesure parce que la securitate un triste
privilège
en plus des personnages traditionnels de
la répression prison déportation
assignation à résidence et bien luz la
violence physique le passage à tabac
pour un mot de trop un mot de travers
quelques individus vous tombe dessus le
soir et votre côté vous frappe
il faut se souvenir que la manifestation
de ce week-end a pour origine un pasteur
protestant poignardé par des inconnus
alors justement ça a bougé et ce
week-end c'était la première fois qu'est
ce qui s'est passé de nouveaux l'écouté
il ya deux raisons qui expliquent que ce
qui se passe actuellement en roumanie
première raison est bien les
entraînements des piles laisse les
roumains savent ce qui se passe un jour
au pays de l'est ils le savent par les
divisions soviétiques hongroise bulgare
qui maintenant disent la vérité sur ce
qu'il a donc un effet d'entraînement et
puis seconde raison des raisons
économiques la situation économique
roumaine est absolument catastrophique
le chauffage est limité à 7 heures par
jour dans un pays où il fait moins 20
oumma 30 degrés l'hiver il n'y a plus
rien à manger pour avoir de la viande
les files d'attentes commence à 4 heures
du matin j'ai bien souvent pour rien
merci jacques à l'est toujours cette
information à propos de la
tchécoslovaquie c'est l'écrivain vaclav
havel qui sera probablement élue à la
ysance de la république avant la fin de
l'année c'est le nouveau premier
ministre mme ariane khalfa qui la
proposait 50 mille étudiants et lycéens
s'étaient d'ailleurs rassemblés cet
après midi à prague pour réclamer
l'élection de vaclav havel à la
présidence en france
haro sur l'immigration clandestine comme
l'avait demandé le président de la
république toute une série de mesures
ont été annoncées ce matin à l'issue de
ce comité interministériel à matignon
pour limiter le nombre d'entrées
clandestine en france le premier
ministre a notamment annoncé qu'il y
aura moins visa de tourisme attribués et
que la politique d'immigration de la
france sera expliquée aux pays concernés
il s'agit donc de freiner l'immigration
clandestine venue aussi bien par exemple
de yougoslavie du sri-lanka de
l'allemagne ou de la turquie
le statut de demandeur d'asile va aussi
être reconsidérée alors tout cela passe
bien sûr par une meilleure surveillance
des frontières notamment dans les
aéroports c'est le rôle de la police de
l'air et des frontières
agnès poirier et jean-marie lequertier
ont passé une journée ordinaire avec
cette police à roissy
wolf 0,33 en provenance d'abidjan pour
la police de l'air et des frontières
c'est un vol sensible tous les passagers
doivent présenter un visa de tourisme un
certificat d'hébergement et des
ressources suffisantes
un jour ou cinq jours en france cinq
jours seulement ouais mais ça change
tout pour faire une nouvelle réservation
d'avion là et vous ne pouvez pas parce
que vous ne pouvez pas réserver avant le
31 décembre
sa réservation d'hôtel à l'air bonne et
les fausses son visa ne couvre pas toute
la durée de son séjour elle ne rentrera
pas en france elle va prendre le
prochain avion pour abidjan et vous
entendez fin mai 10 à roissy on a même
créé une brigade spécialisée la brigade
mobile d'immigration pas de formation
particulière pour ces fonctionnaires ils
épluchent les papiers à la loupe et
vérifie systématiquement et de fait le
nombre des nos ennemis augmente au terme
d'une année d'existence
enfin fin 84 8 sata aperçu que le nombre
d'étrangers admis en prenant deux pays
sensibles à lui augmenté de 200%
car de séjour falsifiés faux ordres de
missions mauvaise photo tout échoue dans
le bureau de l'officier de quart c'est
lui qui va trancher c'est pas suffisant
bacrot balkans
né à ce que tous les papiers que vous
avez demandé de ne pas dire que vous
avez demandé
sur le papier rien n'est pas fixée pour
sebastian cela suffit l'obsession des
policiers c'est le faux touristes celui
qui une fois son visa expiré va rester
en france et devenir un clandestin
cette femme zaïroise va repartir pour
kinshasa sans avoir mis le pied sur le
territoire français elle a bien un visa
mais se dit délégué commercial d'une
société qui n'existe pas elle attendra
son avion dans le salon bleu c'est en
zone internationale
nous ne pourrons pas l'accompagner un
secteur interdit aux journalistes
réservé aux passagers en transit au nom
ennemis comme elle et à ceux qui alors
rentré en france demandent l'asile
politique
comme ces familles somaliennes le
ministre l'intérieur leur a délivré ce
matin sauf conduit leur demande d'asile
va être examinée mais ils ont dû
attendre plus d'une semaine en zone
internationale sans aucun confort
dormant par terre que l'on statue sur
leur sort
une brigade spécialisée à roissy mais
des fonctionnaires parfois sceptique
sans illusion il s'agit surtout
affirment les syndicats de faire monter
les statistiques pour les faux touristes
et les vrais clandestins il reste
tellement de poids le passage perméable
sur nos frontières il à propos des
aéroports je vous précise que c'est
demain mercredi que des mesures de
sécurité exceptionnelles vont être
prises à partir de demain mercredi
il s'agit des procédures de sécurité
antiterroriste mise en place dans les
lieux publics pour les fêtes de noël en
politique
une motion de censure déposée par
l'opposition l'intergroupe rpr udf et
udc va déposer dans la soirée une motion
de censure sur la politique de santé du
gouvernement
refondre la grille des salaires des
fonctionnaires vaste projet c'est l'un
des travaux d'hercule auquel s'est
attelée michel rocard dès le début de
son gouvernement
c'est par là que passe la modernisation
de la fonction publique
les négociations pour la nouvelle grille
se sont engagés aujourd'hui elles seront
longues
véronique auger ce n'est que le début
d'un long marathon
l'objectif n'est pas de casser la
fameuse grille des fonctionnaires mais
de la moderniser le ministre de la
fonction publique a dès le départ
bornet la route de la négociation
d'abord priorité à l'évolution des bas
salaires ensuite la fonction publique
doit garder la porte ouverte aux sans
diplôme non seulement parce que cela
fait partie de sa mission mais en plus
parce qu'elle en a besoin
il faut cependant qu'elles organisent
leur formation et leur déroulement de
carrière
enfin le ministre mais les syndicats en
gare cette réforme doit être supportable
économiquement elle doit être étalé sur
sept ans en face les partenaires sociaux
lance deux avertissements c'est pas avec
des demi-mesures
on s'en sortira par conséquent il faudra
véritablement que le gouvernement se
rend compte qu'en engageant cette
négociation il s'engage dans un grand
chantier qui demandera du temps et de
l'argent
nous avons perdu en gros 10 % de pouvoir
d'achat entre 82 et 88 donc pour nous au
minimum une réforme de la grille
indiciaire ça doit consister à donner
aux fonctionnaires leur bus à dire au
moins de rattrapage du pouvoir d'achat
82 88 et ensuite nous sommes tout à fait
d'accord pour discuter et des nouvelles
que 10 en qualifications force ouvrière
chypre cette réforme à 50 milliards de
francs quoi qu'il en soit il faudra du
temps pour changer cette grille qui date
de 1946 la sphère des 10 de billancourt
elle est en principe terminé la justice
a définitivement tranché la cour de
cassation instance ultime à rejeter le
pourvoi
elle a donc décidé que les 10 ne serait
pas réintégré à la régie renault
la cgt et le parti communiste crie au
scandale
maryse mano pour eux c'est terminé les
10 de renault ne reviendront jamais à
billancourt
la cour de cassation a rejeté leur
pourvoi
malgré l'avis de l'avocat général qui
souhaitait la réintégration de huit
d'entre eux
il y à peine un mois la ministre il ne
jouera pas pour les fautes lourdes qui
leur sont reprochés
la justice de classe vient de trancher
et las les sanctions sont maintenus moi
je dis très nettement que ni le
président de la république que ni le
premier ministre ne peuvent se
considérer blanchi dans ce mauvais coup
fausses factures droit commun
tout le monde est gracié par contre les
travailleurs eux sont frappés la cgt
aura bien du mal à mobiliser pour les 10
de renault les 4000 ouvriers de
billancourt qui seront licenciés en 92
la régie a décidé de frapper fort une
vingtaine de militants qui avaient
organisé il ya quelques jours une visite
interdite des ateliers sont eux aussi
menacés de sanctions un seul syndicat la
cgt paralysant ce moment toute la presse
en france la distribution des nmpp et en
grève comme la cgt a le monopole dans
cette entreprise les journaux la plupart
des journaux ne sont plus distribués et
cela va continuer c'est une catastrophe
pour certains de nos confrères and gas
du rejet des rotatives qui tourne pour
rien c'est tout le coeur du problème
face à face les 2500 ouvriers cgt du
livre qui bloque toute la distribution
des journaux et les patrons de presse
qui perdent chaque jour des sommes
exorbitantes
aucun de ces numéros du quotidien le
monde n'est pas revenue cet après midi
dans les kiosques des piquets de grève
ont en effet empêché la sortie des
camions des ateliers d'imprimerie vers
les centres de tri et d'expédition au
cinquième jour de grève cette
distribution de la presse à paris mais
aussi en province bute toujours sur la
prime réclamée par les grévistes 7750
francs sur 14 mois
la direction elle propose six mille
francs sur 18 mois
un conflit qui n'a toujours pas trouvé
d'issue tout l'après-midi ouvriers la
distribution des nems pp d'une part et
patron de presse d'autre part se sont
réunis pour tenter de sortir de
l'impasse les patrons qui ce soir-là
sommes une team à taux de grévistes le
travail ne reprend pas demain nous avons
deux formules qui sont prêtes soit la
mise au chômage technique de toutes les
autres catégories
j'entends de la réserve
jusqu aux rotatives puisque tous ses
salariés la travaille et on ne va pas
bien entendu rédigé ni composé lien
primes et des journaux qui ne seront pas
distribués et la deuxième formule qui
est prête elle aussi c'est tout
simplement la sortie globale de tous les
titres parisiens des nmpp et
l'organisation par nos soins et par tout
moyen approprié de notre propre
distribution menaces auxquelles n'ont
pas encore réagi les ouvriers cgt du
livre depuis trois heures les grévistes
de la distribution et même des faits
sont réunis en assemblée générale de
leurs réponses aux patrons de presse
dépend la reprise des négociations et la
réapparition des journaux dans les
kiosques dès demain une décision
importante va être prise par l'assemblée
nationale cette nuit dorénavant les
victimes d'attentats seront assimilées
aux victimes civiles de la guerre
on en parlait depuis longtemps ce sera
officiel à partir de demain en principe
les victimes d'attentats seront ainsi
beaucoup mieux indemnisés et aider
l'autre et ce pauvre depuis 85 les
victimes d'attentats ici celui des
magasins du printemps sont indemnisés
par le fonds de garantie avant cette
date chaque dossier était réglé cas par
cas par l'état comme celui de monsieur
et madame cruise skis grièvement blessé
au grand véfour en décembre 83 désormais
leur soeur est identique à celui d'un
blessé civil de guerre
les victimes d'attentats que vont
pouvoir bénéficier premièrement des
soins gratuits de la dispense du ticket
modérateur des appareillages gratuit de
l'accès aux centres médicaux spécialisés
des militaires au val de grâce à l'école
l'école militaire
les emplois réservés les cartes
d'invalidité et le statut de pupille de
la nation qui concerne plus
particulièrement les nombreux orphelins
et nous avons eu lors de l'attentât
contre le dc10 côté indemnisations peu
de changements
le fonds de garantie prenait déjà en
charge l'intégralité des dommages subis
mais si les victimes s'estime encore les
et elles pourront toujours déposer un
recours pour une pension supplétives ce
texte sera rétroactif à partir du 1er
janvier 82 l'allemagne de l'est nous y
venons tout va très vite en allemagne de
l'est dès le premier sommet
interallemande qui mettait face à face
le chancelier helmut kohl et le premier
ministre de rda hans modrow à dresde en
allemagne de l'est
dix-sept premières ' réunion des
décisions très concrètes ont été
annoncées elles vont toutes dans le sens
d'une libéralisation j'y arriverai du
régime est allemand et de son ouverture
vers l'ouest trois exemples avant noël
c'est à dire avant le week-end proches à
la porte de brandebourg sera ouverte
c'est un symbole
d'autre part les visas d'entrée en rda
sont supprimés pour tous les allemands
de l'ouest
et puis autre exemple en ce mode raw a
promis la libération de tous les
prisonniers politiques en allemagne de
l'est
patricia cost
deux décisions qu'ils prendront effet
dans les jours qui viennent
effectivement lors de ce sommet un
terreau allemand premièrement
extrêmement symbolique la porte de
brandebourg sera ouverte dès le 24
décembre pour les piétons seulement
deuxièmement les allemands de l'ouest
vont pouvoir pénétrer sans visa en
allemagne de l'est en revanche pour le
traité de coopération entre les deux
allemagnes rien de précis mais les deux
parties d'après monsieur cole se serait
rapproché sur certains points en fait
une frange de la population en allemagne
de l'aide préfère avancer doucement
resserrer les liens
avant d'envisager une réunification
car si de nombreux allemands de l'est
ont accueilli le chancelier kohl devant
l'hôtel bellevue où se sont déroulés les
entretiens avec chaleur des signes
d'hostilité à une réunification trop
rapides ont aussi été remarqué le
président mitterrand arrive demain en
allemagne de l'est pour une visite
officielle de trois jours il va succéder
ainsi au chancelier kohl et il parlera à
lui aussi de la réunification de
l'allemagne
à noter en effet comme le disait
patricia qu'aujourd'hui à berlin-est des
milliers de manifestants se sont
rassemblés ce soir pour protester contre
la réunification de l'allemagne
une manifestation à l'occasion de la
visite officielle en rda du chancelier
kohl le mouvement d'opposition nouveau
forum s'était associé à cette
manifestation de protestation
d'autre part cette information encore
les échanges d'espions entre allemagne
de l'est et allemagne de l'ouest aurait
déjà commencé
il doit concerner une trentaine d'agents
et à propos d' espionnage ce document
exceptionnel
markus wolf s'explique le célèbre maître
espion qui m inspire et john le carré
ce célèbre espion a maintenant 66 il a
réussi à traverser la tempête il a été
même nommé dans un groupe de conseillers
du nouveau numéro un du parti
on le dit aussi proche de mikhaïl
gorbatchev cet homme donc c'est expliqué
à martine laroche-joubert notre envoyé
spécial
homme de l'ombre pendant près de 30 ans
personne ne connaissait son visage las
des plus grands espions du siècle chef
des services secrets est allemand
retraité depuis deux ans ils s'exposent
aujourd'hui en pleine lumière et devient
conseiller du nouveau gouvernement
parcours surprenant d'un juif allemand
réfugié en urss en 1933 à la montée du
nazisme est devenu officier de l'armée
rouge
d'ailleurs il possède toujours un
passeport soviétique revenus en
allemagne de l'est en 45
il se lance dans les services secrets
comment sa légende il est là des héros
des romans d'espionnage de john le carré
ses faits d'armes tombeur du chancelier
willy brandt avec la taupe ou une paire
guillaume créateur des réseaux de
séducteur de secrétaire il a même réussi
à retourner un chef du contre espionnage
c'est l'église de saint nicolas
laprise ancien de la vie raconte-t-il
dans une étrange dans l'allemagne
d'aujourd'hui
secoué par les règlements de comptes lui
le chef de la police secrète se promène
sans crainte apparente
il a également envie de parler ce à quoi
ils n'étaient pas habitués
difficile d'aller chez lui les
dirigeants est-allemands n'apprécie pas
que les journalistes pénètre dans leur
domicile
alors il cherche un café sans se cacher
trop de musique à les dix rencontres ici
par hasard la d euros de son unique
roman trucks a paru il ya six mois
maintenant il écrit aussi comme john le
carré et il en est fier
mais vous savez je pense que beaucoup de
gens ont vu dans mon livre une sorte
d'anticipation de la perez 3 et carré de
la glace d'eau
étrange tout de même que cet homme
patron des services secrets est allemand
pendant 26 ans soit aujourd'hui
conseiller dé nouveaux dirigeants sur la
voie du changement
vous savez les services secrets ne sont
liés directement aux changements actuels
bien sûr si la politique du ventre dans
une période de détente
la tâche des services secrets change
elle aussi grâce à gunther guillot vous
avez réussi à déstabiliser la république
fédérale en faisant tomber le chancelier
ouest allemand willy brandt
vous le regrettez je voudrais bien
connaître le service secret qui aurait
refusé
je pense ne rien avoir à me reprocher
mais j'assume quand même la
responsabilité d'une politique de
sécurité abusive
chaque citoyen qui exprimait une pio
différence de cette foire subissaient
des représailles
j'ai créé précédent évidemment je
n'étais pas toujours d'accord avec cette
politique
mais vu ma position je suis obligé
aujourd'hui de l'assumer
une dizaine de jeunes le carré à dire
laquelle grands espions ne meurent
jamais qu'est ce que vous en pensez bien
mourir un jour sans laisser de traces
chacun a laissé des traces d'une manière
ou d'une autre
et s'il a quelque chose à raconter à nam
et même à écrire il laissera une trace
encore plus marrant
avec markus wolf nous découvrons aussi
que non seulement les grands espions ne
meurt pas mais qu'ils peuvent renaître
en démocrate venu du froid d'autres
informations maintenant résumé par anne
consignes et d'abord la sphère de motion
où sont passés les fûts de dioxine de
seveso ont-ils réellement quitté la
décharge de montchanin
il y avait une confrontation aujourd'hui
entre le ministre brice lalonde et les
élus de saône et loire
selon brice lalonde les fûts de seveso
ne peuvent pas être montchanin ils ont
été détruits à bâle et le ministre
affirme qu'il en fournira la preuve
mais il pourrait y avoir d'autres si une
enquête doit être ouverte sondage de la
décharge analyses de l'air est suivi
médical des habitants
assemblée générale du cnpf aujourd'hui à
paris pour le façon des patrons françois
périgot deux priorités la réduction des
charges sociales la conquête économique
de l'ess et mis en garde contre le
retient l'interventionnisme de l'état
nouvelles inculpations dans la sphère
des fausses factures de nancy gérard
gautier secrétaire général de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie de meurthe et
moselle
il aurait avoué avoir reçu de l'argent
du maire de toul jacques gosso pour
favoriser la décision de construction
d'un supermarché à vandoeuvre
edouard chevardnadzé en visite au siège
de l'alliance atlantique à bruxelles
une première historique le ministre des
affaires étrangères soviétique mais les
occidentaux en garde contre toute
pression sur la hervé a en vue d'une
réunification allemande
mauvaise humeur à la bourse de paris
l'indicé cac 40 perd 0 71%
le dollar s'échange lit en hausse à 592
au cours officiel
au programme télé à partir de début
janvier bien vous serez gâté sa bouche
sur antenne 2 mais aussi sur fr3 ce
matin notre président comme un philippe
guillôme a présenté à la presse les
nouvelles grilles de programmes beaucoup
d'innovations et surtout une
complémentarité réelle entre les deux
chaînes qui permettra de satisfaire les
goûts de tous les téléspectateurs
laurent monsieur antenne 2 avec une
grille de programmes qui bouge et une
orientation marquée vers les
documentaires et les magazines
christine ockrent revient avec trois
émissions mensuelles bernard à nous
proposera chaque mercredi à 22h15 my
taylor is rich une sorte de super
assiette anglaise toujours à 22h15 mais
le lundi des documentaires avec
notamment lé nouveau far west de michel
audrain et mémoire et histoire de
christine ockrent
autre nouveauté tous les jours juste
avant 20 heures jean yanne avec une
émission au titre évocateur rire à rire
à pas côté informations plusieurs
magazines de 30 minutes sur la santé les
sciences l'éducation est un pari avec un
magazine de grands reportages le jeudi à
20h30 parce quand n 2 c'est la chaîne de
l'information antenne 2 c'est la chaîne
de la qualité l'information et la
qualité
c'est à 20h30 enfin pour jouer la
complémentarité avec fr3 plusieurs
émissions sont déplacés les chiffres et
les lettres passe à 17 heures l'heure de
vérité descend à 22h15 le mardi et du
côté de chez fred est programmée pour
les noctambules à minuit
et nous ne serons toujours fidèle au
poste voilà le tiercé quinté plus
c'était aujourd'hui à enghien
curieusement dans le prix de vincennes
on va voir les résultats et les rapports
tout de suite le tir fait 16 11 14 de
1917 fondant lors des 450 500 dans le
désordre le quinté + 16 11 14 19 et deux
là je vous laisse lire les rapports
c'est vraiment trop gros
la météo s'est tout de suite avec sophie
davant la dernière édition ce sera henri
sannier aux alentours de minuit après
les dossiers de l'écran
et puis demain premier journal 7 heures
gérard morin dans télématin à demain
bonsoir